to be clear I subscribed to her only
fans account it's my first time
subscribe to holy vans account and
listen you guys called them as simple so
I wanted to get into the mind of a simp
and I gotta know Lee fence in order to
catch a simp you got abusive predator
you gotta be a predator that's right
ask Chris Hansen I'm sure he's got some
kids in this closet so we'll talk about
that later
what is a simple what is this simp a
simp the opposite of a pimp time to F
put a Pete a pimp is a manager and a
simp is a customer who never gets the
goods you paid but you didn't receive
your product but you keep paying you
show no hope that you're gonna receive
some product eventually exactly
basically it's a guy who rolls out the
mat for women hoping to get some and
never does now looking into this I dub
situation if you aren't familiar he's a
big creator on this platform makes a lot
of content commentary series called
content cop that made it very popular
back in the day Internet is a place
people won't stop telling us cover this
cover this apparently idubbbz his
girlfriend who's a streamer has made an
only fans account and everybody has gone
crazy they've been sending me means
sending me messages do you think man
honestly when I saw this I'm like how is
this a thing I will attest the fact I
think for a lot of people is not a thing
people are just posting meap's and
they're having a laugh and I think
that's fine
you should be able to crack jokes about
that let's all laugh but then there's
people who were really like mad like I
saw some comments I was like whoa you
guys are like legitimately Devastator or
some people are like really angry at him
and and my thing is like why do you care
why are people so invested in the lives
of people who are in the media I don't
care about what people do in their
personal lives unless it's somehow
hypocritical regards to what they
exposed in the media you know if you
were like oh I'm an advocate for women's
rights and then behind closed doors you
own females or whatever that might be a
problem and it's worth bringing to light
right because you don't practice what
you preach to do I want a girl who has
an only fans count no but guess what is
not my relationship so
I don't care do I want to grow who's
going to give me a golden shower no but
guess what other people do and I don't
care because it's not my relationship I
don't understand what the problem is
with somebody being flying with the fact
that their girl has an only face
he seems very supportive good for them
you know some people but I don't feel
like he's okay with it you don't know
what he feels
your intuition could be very well off he
could be actually fine with it if he is
what's the problem why do people care
that much my suspicion is that people
really love this man and they really
dislike her because she's shown evidence
of being a bad person I don't know if
this is accurate but what is being said
of all there's some footage of her
saying some stuff on stream that I'm
like Matt here's my thing it's kind like
when you have a friend who's dating
someone you're really disliking you know
as a bad person if you go to your friend
good yeah she's bad she's a bad person
dump or dump her what does your friend
do stays with her right and you start to
get frustrated you get mad cuz you like
leave her and what ends up happening he
grows more distant from you and more
into that person what you have to
understand is if she is as bad as you
guys believe her to be it's gonna be on
him to discover that for himself advise
him once once this is known as no I mean
there's nothing much you can see I've
gotten people that are not in the best
relationship I say once and I'm but your
friend yeah but I've learned in life
that this does not work but you're a
friend they're fans you know the word
people when they're your fan and I'm a
bit scared of that to be honest with you
I was titled yes that exactly a fan of
yours and I am talking into some of you
sometimes I see some the comments still
not used to it and then sometimes it
really irritates me hmm yeah when
someone goes I don't preach you [ __ ] who
are you I don't even know you
I don't know you in order to ask for any
advice and then you come here and you
impose yourself on who are you you
you're willing to take it or not I don't
go to you you do men there's a
difference I'm speaking in a camera and
I put it out there I don't exactly know
who I'm speaking with
I'm just speaking to a camera you can
always tune that it's not the same thing
that if I walk in the street and you
come up to me if you're imposing
yourself on me and I have to listen to
you and I'm like oh you have to do this
and that and that we give advices but
you don't have to take none of them I
don't know you are I think this whole
like simple craze that I keep hearing
about
I think idubbbz is like girlfriends
announcement and then there's simple
business it's all cup happening at the
same time it's like the perfect
intersection between what I believe is
like there's anti pro-women
movements meaning like a lot of men are
really just annoyed to a certain degree
with like female entitlement with pro
female groups with you know alimony
women not wanting to date down I've
never seen a proliferation online of men
just being really upset or sometimes
justifiably so and so I see all this
stuff right and even on YouTube there's
a huge proliferation of that kind of
content I know cuz I've helped create so
much of it and I benefited from it
because I see some of the comment
sections and I'm like whoa okay y'all
going really far
people generally saw him as guy who
won't take from anybody seeing him have
a woman who would dare to show other men
her private parts which then lowers him
like how dare he be accepting of that
kind of thing
they saw someone that they thought would
never want to be okay with that be okay
with that and some of them felt like it
was a personal loss for themselves let's
say we they felt like women are winning
all the time
here's another woman who is not
deserving who's winning again does that
make sense there's that there's a lot of
things there's what you just mentioned
the intersection of that but I would add
a third point is the trends the trends
of the words when one word come out it
becomes a trend it becomes super trendy
and a lot of people use it and sometimes
overuse it and they don't mean oh the
distance they don't know the definition
if she's gonna this is gonna fling it
out I remember what work came out
certain people were using boy
people didn't know when and then it
became Miss Minchin man
everything is a boy you're why he
wearing that shirt if it's a boy why
he's driving like that you're driving
like a boy I had a girl I had a girl
tell me I made her a you know a salmon
dinner one time salmon dinner right neh
really fancy she enjoyed it we had two
more dates I said I'm not interested I
said what you made me some and dinner
why would you do that if you're not
interested in something more serious I
was like what it's like you're you know
like that's not what the definition of
boy is because I made you a song Simon
dinner I didn't make you a salmon dinner
I was hungry you was there but people
use it like that row yo that's dope
that's dope that's though yo this is lit
this is lit oh this is and everybody use
that yeah now I think one of the words
of the moment is simple everything is a
simple when you don't agree with someone
you will fail sit with one of them
there's a bunch of words like that that
are there's that trendy if it was like
for example mmm a year ago that would
happen he wouldn't be called a simple I
don't think he would have been called a
kook you know nothing people are mad
because his girl made only fans how dare
you that's an insult or this and that
I'm like I just don't understand how
people can consume so much of this prawn
and then get mad when someone is dating
somebody who makes prom
I mean you helped create the market no
these people need to feel alone
somebody's daughter somebody's sister
somebody's girlfriend has to make the
prom what's the point
you can't consume the matter and then be
mad once like if people are okay with it
you contribute to the normalization of
said thing I don't know why there's such
a stigma with this kind of stuff are we
trying to say that making prawn is bad
yeah it shows the problem it shows a
problem right now how like the way the
ex-workers are being seen whether it's
Tams whether it's rippers all of that
it's all the apocrypha of the respect
that they have that they will consume
but they will donate when they need to
get on it I really don't get that I
would hope that if somebody's engaging
and that kind of stuff that the people
around them are supportive you know like
me I don't want my family members of my
dog do that but if
they were a group of their own volition
I don't want to alienate them or shame
them for it I would say I'm not cool
with it but I still support you he's
cool with it
that's like one of the best case
scenarios see if I understand why y'all
mad like maybe I'm missing I said it
before in a previous you know I don't
think that kind of work is honorable
that being said I don't what PO pointed
and I surely don't shame people who do
it if he's okay with it then why you mad
I know people who hate that and then
they'll go use the services of a knight
Walker yeah and I'm just like you're
creating a demand you have urges someone
helps you with your cravings it's not
like this is a bad thing some people
have heard they compared it to crack
it's not like crack okay this is a
healthy urge that we have to get off is
a good thing
I'm telling you right now there's so
many times that I've come to Prague and
I'm glad I did because I would have
probably made a worse decision if I had
it and I'm not even saying that when I
say that it cannot get to a point where
that's not the point but at its core you
need to relieve some tension yeah it's
normal
sometimes you just want to skip the date
and get straight to the business number
people for the number of people that go
to Vegas you're just gonna go to the
casino and play games rough I went to
Amsterdam I've used the red night with
the the red-light district like it was
great it's great it's Lord 50 euros on
the table protection because it's go at
it legal simple if we call it safe
there's no date it's no three-hour
affair pay 15 minutes I paid for 15 I
was done in ten amen nobody was mad he's
only paid for two positions I've already
said too much
all this is you guys are good we talking
yeah I was like sweets position she's
like more money like no funny and I said
nah so I paid for only fans never had
only fans before I said yo let me check
this out and it's interesting I want
honor only fans to see all these ludes
that everyone was talking about mm-hmm I
went there ready for rated R it was
rated pg-13
really yes there's not that bad let me
put it this way her Instagram which is
public to everyone is rated pg-13 or her
only fans was pretty much rated team
there was no Lutz at all
I always hoping to be rated T for Tatas
like I was ready to see everything bruh
Tatas brough not even rated for that no
not even like Scott you know scotch tape
yeah
[Music]
hold on
right now we're go find me right cough
I'm in Hana hub you're the premium
account
it's free for everyone right now yeah
usually know how much it is
mmm $9.99 you mean to tell me that in
these trial times I'm gonna be $9.99 for
just Instagram stuff brah I've seen
Instagram accounts with way more skin
than this I think Twitter accounts so
it's pretty disappointing I mean go on
and do your thing boy ain't nobody mad
at you but oh you don't see what I sent
her a message I mean if you get a simple
go all the way please respond
[Music]
anyways too invested to invest the
people that are buying the only fans or
the since can you not include me in that
I will do whatever I want I've even
included you that you included yourself
in that you all people wearing blue
jackets our sips yeah were you talking
to me yeah well you saw amend your
definition you did say in order to catch
the same you have to be a thing
therefore you're a simp for a month for
research purposes still assume research
purposes yes a cop was undercover really
yeah I that's on you and if the
engagement is an actor who's acting
really woody acts like it's not actor
it's called method acting bro you're not
method acting super super Sam okay so it
is what it is it's not even all the
people that are on the only fan account
that are simple I'm not even gonna go as
far as that
all right some people want to see just
more and that's what they have the paper
would be get you know I mean they are
not all since there's probably some of
what that are but some just want to see
that person and a little bit more
pictures and that's it hmm that's it
just pay for this Nami doesn't make you
a symptom
no what about going to the rippers yeah
no I don't use them I don't think so
either
no yeah I think that makes you say it's
not because you buy it through the only
fan account that yourself there's some
people that go to the rippers that are
Sims there are some people that buy into
the only fan account that are but it's
not all put them in the pot okay there's
a camera there and that's it I'm also
here whatever first you call me a sip
and then you just gonna act like I don't
exist
bro whatever anyways yes we've be into
cameras you're right you're there are
more than just here acknowledge my
presence and then encourage my presence
you know what limo
listen if you don't start treating me
better I'm gonna have self-esteem issues
and then I'm gonna start an old fans
account and that we gonna have real
problems
you started only fan accounts I'm pretty
sure they're pulling your ladies I want
to see that you're gonna make math doe
broke every time you drop some like yes
so I date more than my brother now you
know I mean Oh who's like ooh you got a
brother my one no so if you wanna start
although only banner counts boo boo
honey chicken Jerri child honey bunny
bunch with a slice of lime and a cherry
on top
by all means glow make your money boo
boo ain't nobody mad about that that's
right we're gonna have real problems
how ladies want that yes they do and if
I make one I'm a dub myself a pimp I
dubs myself a pimp
carry on